Carmen Electra gets emotional
remembering her late mentor Prince to
lose his life is shocking I didn't think
this day would come
iconic musician Prince died on Thursday
at 57 and Hollywood is torn apart
especially Carmen Electra who was
discovered by Prince in 1991 when she
was pursuing a music career I learned a
lot from him he was my mentor I've
learned work ethic from him kindness to
have boundaries many people lived in you
he was rooting for you he would be he
was your biggest cheerleader and he was
like no you're gonna make it and you
know he he did that for me he gave me
confidence the 44 year old also revealed
the pair dated while working on
Electra's debut album but explained why
they kept things under wraps I remember
he said you know I want he's like I
believe in you and I want people to take
you serious
and people know that you're my
girlfriend they're gonna think that I'm
just doing this for you because you're
my girlfriend and he says so if anyone
asks you he said you tell him too many
men not enough time 25 years later it's
clear the legendary rocker still holds a
special place in Electra's heart thank
you for making me who I am today thank
you for believing me and giving the
opportunities that no one would ever
given me